this is a production of cornell
university
thank you gillian and uh thank you for
the invitation
um this is i i would say this is
probably my first
full seminar that i've done this way so
um
while i'm disappointed that i won't hear
all the laughter from my hilarious jokes
i'll just
i have a good imagination so
i know that you guys are all entertained
infotained
um so it is a great pleasure and as i
was preparing for this i realized i
emailed gillian yesterday we've
we've known each other now for two
decades which is
um our friendship is almost able to
drink legally
um i i'm
really excited to be talking about uh
genes and phenotypes
um i'll first so the outline for the
talk is i will first
talk about emsl and and
how it works as a user facility what we
can do
in collaboration with you
uh and and then i'll go into some of my
own research
um all kind of talking about uh genes to
phenotypes
and phenotypes to genes and um
without further ado i'll just start um
m's this is a picture of emsl
it is i think it's the size of about
three costcos
is what i've heard um it's a massive lab
um
in in the middle of nowhere in
washington state about three
250 miles east of seattle um
along the columbia river in a smallish
community
where the department of energy
or its precursors made plutonium for
nuclear weapons now we're involved in
cleanup
and emsl is a part of
the pacific northwest national lab where
a doe lab that focuses on all of doe's
missions including basic research
and so emsl is this user facility and
it was founded in 1996
so we're getting close to our 25th
anniversary
um we're funded out of the office of
biological environmental research part
of doe
um and we and we address science
problems that are uh relevant to energy
and environment that can use
analytical chemistry math computational
sciences all
some combination of that to accelerate
research and solve problems and our
budget's about 44 million dollars
a year we support over 700 users per
year
and um i'll just say that we
we basically run i run peer review
processes
for many or most of the
projects that come through so it's a
competitive process it's open to
anyone and we really focus on uh
doe mission science and
in this case it would be biotechnology
biofuels plant genomics
um so things that are probably in all of
your wheelhouse
so i'll talk a little bit just a brief
background functional and systems
biology is the area
that i lead there's a kind of parallel
area
and environmental research
that also makes use of the same kinds of
tools
my area is really interested in omics
and microscopy that support
understanding say carbon cycling
via microbes and plants
at the molecular level also
biotechnology for biofuels
so i like to say anything that you need
to do
after you get a genome for your organism
we can help you with
and we're organized into integrated
research platforms
and i don't want to go into too much
depth about how we're organized but
suffice it to say we have uh
capabilities that span
all kinds of imaging from light to
electron microscopy
we have a brand new cryo-em so we're
getting into protein structure
um in cellular dynamics we're interested
in
what it sounds like the how cells are
dynamic
we have technologies to look at cells
do some level of omics that single with
single cell resolution
i'll talk a little bit about one of
those technology and then functional
omics is
really your proteomics metabolomics
glycomics
transcriptomics pretty much any omic
uh there's a lot of them out there and
our focus there is we we have
nmr and mass spectrometry as well as
some sequencers
and so we do all kinds of different
permutations on this
i can only touch on a few things but i'm
happy to elaborate if you want to email
i can send information and you can also
go to our website
so we just went through a road mapping
exercise
and in biology our
we are developing capabilities
technologies expertise
that will lead in with the big addition
to the big audacious goal
of what we call the digital phenome
platform but really what this is is a
research platform that would
allow prediction of phenotype based on
any number of experiments we could do to
get that protein function
and for example we have computational
chemistry capabilities that can really
delve into
enzyme active site chemistry we want to
visualize metabolic pathways
so we want to not only understand what's
doing what is
what proteins and other small molecules
are doing what they're doing but
where are they in the cell how are they
interacting with their environment
um visual proteomics is a really
exciting platform we're developing
think of it as a space filling model of
a cell where
we're combining protein structure
information
with location in the cell with protein
complexes to really kind of pack that
cell
and conceptually pack that cell and
understand
how um how
what the phenotype based on how that
cell is packed with proteins and
metabolites
so we um we use a number of different
capabilities to answer questions um in
our own research we can develop genetics
but we have
as i mentioned ultrastructure we do
microfluidics
uh we're interested in incorporating
modeling in with our experiments
um this is let's see if that rotates now
um
this is uh super resolution light
microscopy
of uh urea lipolytica yeast that
accumulates lipid those are two lipid
droplets in there and then
a calcophore stain for the cell wall and
you can see
some nice bud scars there and then we we
worked
with users to combine all this data into
kind of an integrated picture and we're
developing tools along all these
platforms see here we go
so this is just a quick example of a
user project
this is one where we were looking at
neurosphere crassa and we did
uh kind of relative relative uh
quantitation of
the the full proteome of neurospora uh
crassa across a circadian time course so
every two hours
for i believe 48 hours in triplicate and
with a mutant
and uh working with jennifer hurley and
jay dunlap
um jay-z dartmouth and jennifer's at
rensselaer polytechnic
institute and what we found essentially
was
nothing too surprising we were able to
identify a number of
circadian proteins
whose level changes um in uh
across time and the the
i would say not surprising results uh
but one that
was important was that circadian
transcripts don't necessarily lead to
circadian levels of proteins and vice
versa if a protein has a circadian
abundance so it goes up and down
with a circadian rhythm it doesn't
necessarily mean that there is
a transcript that does that as well so
what it really points to
is um post transl post-translational
regulation
of um proteins over time
and really the complexity that's
involved and so we're
working um i mean obviously this was a
massive project
uh we've been working with jennifer and
jay
over the last few years and we've looked
at metabolites over circadian time
and these are still kind of in analysis
on published results but also
the circadian phosphoproteome so i i
put this out there as an example of some
of the types of research and the scale
of research that we can do
some of our long-term goals are to
automate some of these
platforms so that we can increase our
throughput
so we also can do modeling
and and are able to work with users some
users want to
collaborate with us and get additional
grants and so
that's what happened here uh we're
working with
this team on an nih doe modeling grant
um this is one of our really cool
instruments it's one of two in the world
it's a 21 tesla fticr mass spectrometer
it has amazing resolution such that
um the the mass accuracy
is able to uh is so high that we can
identify compounds uh molecular formulas
with really high confidence
the 21 tesla refers to the magnet
and this was a custom magnet
that was built by agilent and then we
also design our instruments so this
is this mass spectrometer was actually
designed and built
at in our in our lab we have fabrication
capabilities but
really a it's cool to look at but what
can it do
um so we this is a real brief experiment
we we had a mutant of
euroa lipolytica and i'll be talking
more about euroa
later but euro is uh yeast
in the saccharomycetenia that when it's
grown on low levels of nitrogen high
levels of
carbon or high carbon to nitrogen ratio
it starts to accumulate lipids which
can be converted easily to biodiesel so
it's of
interest to doe and we were doing mutant
screens and found
uh that we could make what normally is
unpigmented euroa we could make it red
and so um
we worked with one of the developers of
this and found
that we were basically able to isolate
the red pigment shoot it into the mass
spec and
came up with a formula um
uh for proto uh basically came up with a
mass that was consistent with
this red pigment being protopufferin
which is
the last step of heme biosynthesis
before
iron is is added
by fair aquila taste and so we looked at
the isotopic fine structure so you can
not only see
the the high the high abundant isotopes
but also
you know your 13 uh c and
other all the all the different um
stable isotopes that are naturally you
can see them in their natural abundance
this was a sigma proto
porphyrin that we were able to buy as a
standard and you can see that the red
compound from euroa has
the exact same mass spec in fact it's a
little bit purer
we were able to isolate a more pure
isolation of this for our experiments
so i'm going to show one last kind of
capability and then go into
more of my own fungal research but we're
working on
um capabilities to look at transcripts
in cells using fluorescence in situ
hybridization
and so we're able to use different
combinations this
uh use different combinations of
fluorophores to
um look at right now up to 10
genes in a single uh pass
using fluorescence in situ hybridization
and this is what it would look like this
is actually
i believe this is a mammalian cell
where they're looking at genes of
interest in in
insulin production but basically we can
look at uh
10 using kind of a bar a fluorescent bar
code you can
look at the transcript levels within
single cells of up to 10 genes and we're
working to multiplex this so that we can
look at 50
the expression level of 50 genes at one
time
and so imagine now that you're able to
look across a microscope slide you can
start to look with single cell
resolution at transcript levels and
start to look at
how how do transcript levels vary across
a population
of genetically identical uh cells
so one last advertisement uh
kovitz obviously on everybody's mind and
uh in the last stimulus we we got
three million dollars for capital
equipment and used it to purchase some
mass spectrometers and
some capability for our cryoelectron
microscope
and we also got funds that allow us to
actually do covid proposals so
if any of you have we still have some of
these operational funds
for small projects in in the covet arena
contact me if you're interested in
proposing we have a
kind of a rapid
review cycle and again are looking for
uh have the mandate from doe to actually
do covid research
using some of our equipment and then
finally
we do a lot of outreach and we'll be
having a summer school
for graduate students and postdocs and
then
with seminars mixed in for everybody
to look at taking multi-omic data
modeling it and visualizing it um and so
stay tuned for that
um we had a summer school last year on
microbial
modeling uh it was free a lot of
sessions were free
we have some small amount of competition
for like in-depth
classes um it's a week-long it's
um the last one was really uh
quite valuable and exciting so we're
hoping for this
uh to be the same and the idea again is
to
kind of get an in-depth view of tools
for
multi-omic modeling of biochemical
pathways
so i'm going to go into uh
more of my research and i want to start
with an acknowledgement
um these are really a lot of these are
very
large projects and it wouldn't be
possible without a team
so uh at emsl and pnl
uh i'll be highlighting the work of a
two
now staff scientists former postdocs
that stayed on at p9l aaron bredaway and
kyle palmeranning
uh the aspergillus genome work was
co-led with mikhail anderson of dtu
who's now at novazymes
uh all the sequencing was done at jgi
and igor grigoriev
is the head of the fungal genomics
program
um uh ronald devries at the western dyke
institute has
uh done a lot of the growth profiling
and then i'm also a part of the joint
bioenergy institute so i have an
affiliate
a position at lawrence berkeley lab
which leads jay bae and john magnuson a
pnnl colleague actually is the director
of
the fungal biotechnology team i just get
a do science which is kind of nice no
administration there
but um there's we have a small team
there working on fungi so
you'll see an amalgam of all these to
this team of teams to
really bring do fungal biology and and
uh
connect genes and phenotypes
so i i had no idea that when i picked
this title i was i guess i was
prescient that flies would be trending
uh due to the vice presidential debate
so as as gillian mentioned i did a
postdoc looking at fly genetics before i
saw the light and went to fungi
and so i i threw it into the title not
knowing i would be so trendy
um but i'll i'll tell you where i got my
start and connecting genes and
phenotypes
um and just a little graphic to show i'm
interested in that it's been an interest
of mine
since i was started
school in biology of connecting genes
and phenotypes so i i did my
undergraduate work at oregon state
and that was really where i thought oh
man these
fruit flies are really cool uh great
genetics system
little did i know the uh kind of ins and
outs of
fly husbandry until my postdoc years
but in any case i was i i did a postdoc
and um before there was
a genome for drosophila that was
publicly available
so we're talking i guess uh late 90s
here
i did a screen where i looked for
suppressors of
a dominant wing blister phenotype
and um i i think i have
you know i was probably one of the last
people to find their gene
uh before genomes came out there was a
there was
obviously beautiful mapping in in
drosophila
uh basically we found that a signaling
pathway was impaired
uh went to and it caused blisters and so
in this in this mutant phenotype and and
so then when we
when we killed that signaling pathway
uh the flies were i wouldn't say killed
it when we
when we made hypomorphic mutants in the
signaling pathway we were able to
get rid of suppress the blistering um
and it was
actually turned out to be a nuclear
import factor that's able to bring map
kinase into the nucleus
but i want to dwell on drosophila let's
go to fungi and i
i tend to have a as gillian mentioned a
fungal centric
view of at least my professional life
uh fungi are as as
i'm sure many of you agree are really
amazing organisms
and uh i started in fungi kind of on the
faux side you know thinking about plant
disease
working with gillian on cochleobolas uh
but then as i when i went to pnnl
the focus chain my focus changed towards
uh biotechnology and using fungi for
enzyme production or small molecule
production
and from there it's it's been a lot of
fun to sort of like i said connect genes
and phenotypes
so um you know fun some of these fungal
phenotypes are
secretion of enzymes secretion of useful
small molecules so there really is a
nice connection
to biotechnology and in a lot of ways
biofuel production and bio
chemical production which are
central in in doe biology research
mission
so i'm just going to launch right into
it uh one of the projects
that i started a few years ago actually
several years ago now
was through my
joint bioenergy institute connection and
that was
to sequence every single species
one example of every single species of
aspergillus
so that we could really look at the
whole genus of aspergillus and
understand evolution and so
um my co-pi for this was mikhail
anderson
we sequenced uh right now there's about
220 strains there's another
several that are kind of winding their
way finally through the pipeline but
most of the sequencing now is
is complete and we're starting to look
at different sections
of uh aspergillus
the first section excuse me the that we
looked at was aspergillus section negri
which are the black aspergilli
and you can see aspergillus niger is
is one of the key species it produces
citric acid as well as a number of
enzymes for industry
and we can now look and develop
phylogeny based on the whole genome
you can see there's in this column here
is the number of predicted proteins it
varies even within this small
section of aspergillus there's there's
quite a bit of variability
um as as well as variability in the
genome quality
um one of the phenotypes that's
interesting about aspergillus
is that aspergillus niger produces
fumonosin and we discovered this
um when we were sequencing the
aspergillus nitrogenome
probably a decade ago we saw this
cluster that looked like the fusarium
uh fumonosin cluster and it it brought
back memories of
my cochleopoulos years because we'd
found a humanising cluster in
cochleobolas so
when i published this i didn't have we
weren't
it's not within our mission to really
look at look at secondary metabolites
but
there were there was a group at uh dtu
danish technical university
that uh led by jens friesva that became
very interested in the fact that
aspergillus niger which is
this industrial organism and considered
uh generally regarded as safe for
food production etc um
aspergillus niger might make fumonasan
and so they
went and actually found that niger makes
humonison and then
looked at a whole bunch of different
foods
where aspergillus niger has been found
dried fruit
coffee chocolate etc looking to make
sure that fumanasan was not making its
way into the food supply
in that way so there's a whole bunch of
papers on that
when we sequenced all of uh section
negri we could actually look and see
what percentage of the fungi
in this section have the ability to make
humonising what we found was that
um there were a few closely related
species to
aspergillus niger as well as one that's
closely related to aspergillus
carbonarius that have
what i would call the full fumonosyn
cluster and then
several that have just the polyketide
synthase
associated with pumanosin and then
uh one other thing we noticed was a
second polyketide synthase for which we
don't know the
metabolite always seems to
cluster near the fumonos in pks
so again connecting genes and phenotypes
we can look at the secondary metabolite
cluster
uh or secondary metabolites associated
with
each section of aspergillus and then
uh try to draw correlations with what
which secondary metabolite cluster might
make that
particular metabolite so
obviously sequencing genomes kind of
gives you the potential but then you
have to dig in
and do a lot of the hardcore
biochemistry which is
continuing with the group at dtu
so we've also uh just recently published
in nature communications
section flavi which has some wonderful
aspergilli
aspergillus ariza sojay so
uh some really beneficial aspergillus
that are aspergillus species that are
used in food
production in asia so the koji fungi
but also some uh wonder uh
infamous plant pathogens aspergillus
flavous so
in this in this clade or section
actually of aspergillus we have
aflatoxin production we've again looked
at the secondary metabolites and
uh assessed whether um they
which which metabolites are made by
which particular
uh species and then started again to
look at the number of potential
backbones
associated with these these metabolites
i think one thing that is clear is that
the
the genetic potential for these
organisms
when it comes to secondary metabolite
production
is is vast and we really don't have
a great grasp of of all the metabolites
and those connections to
the secondary metabolite clusters still
need to be made
what we've also noted and this is kind
of a busy slide but i can sum it up and
to say that
as many of us know fungi have an
incredible capacity
enzymatic capacity to deconstruct
plant biomass and so when we grow
these aspergilla but when we grow these
aspergilli on
different carbon sources their growth
ability
is is quite uh doesn't necessarily
correlate with
the carbohydrate active enzymes or
caseins
that are in the genome uh indicating a
really critical role
for regulation of these of these genes
in the lifestyle of uh this
this group of fungi so these while these
are very closely related they grow
differently on different substrates
despite having um pretty big kaizen
uh potential and
and and that's again getting to that
phenotype of whether something
how it grows and and relating it to
genes it's
it's much more complex than just being
able to sequence the genome and look at
the catalog of
of caseins so
um i think this is uh yeah so then
finally some unpublished data from
section usti
again the point illustrating that
we can kind of make phylogenetic trees
uh based on on the genes and then
on the genes in each genome and then we
can
see how closely related they are um
and and that and that obviously more
closely related
uh aspergilla have very similar uh
secondary metabolite gene clusters
um again there is still tremendous
diversity even within one
section of aspergilli
so summary for this section
is to say that the the whole genus
genome
project has kind of given us a view of
genetic of the genetic and chemical
diversity with
uh single species resolution uh
tremendous chemical diversity
and regulation is a key component that
is a differentiator between species
that may have similar
catalogs of genes there are two other uh
whole genus projects that are
starting up one in penicillium which is
about 500 different species and then
another one led by randy burka
from formerly of novozymes now at adm on
trichoderma
so stay tuned for those
again i'm going to talk about connecting
genotypes and phenotypes
and i'm going to talk a little bit about
euroa lipolytica
this wonderful oleogenous yeast um
it's it's actually a dimorphic yeast it
grows in yeast form and then hyphal form
uh depending on conditions it's got
reasonably
good molecular genetics not as good as
saccharomyces but
still pretty good and there's metabolic
models available and then several
strains have been sequenced
so this is uh a movie of
euroa growing
it's a time lapse and and it's and what
we've done with this
uh particular strain is that we've
labeled the gf
uh with gfp although it's showing up red
here
um lipid droplet protein and you can see
uh lipid accumulation over time
in this organism um if you look at this
guy over here
you can see it's kind of pretty cool you
can see here's the lipid droplet
and then as the daughter cell buds you
can see the lipid droplet
divide as well and and move into the the
daughter cell
this is the kind of gross response to
nitrogen limitation and we started to
kind of explore the regulatory pathways
involved in not only lipid accumulation
but the morphologies associated with it
so the morphology is really important
and if you talk to anybody
at a in an industry that uses
filamentous fungi especially in in their
work
and to produce enzymes or
metabolites they'll tell you that
morphology is absolutely critical in the
fermenter
um as you might imagine if a fungus kind
of grows in these long haiful masses it
becomes
and you've seen it maybe in shake flasks
it
it becomes very viscous and it's not
really
an optimal bio process and so um
euroa can make hyphy and bioreactors and
that
can kind of really gum up
not to to use an unscientific term the
uh the process and so one of the first
things we did
in this uh euroa process uh our
project that uh um when kyle palmerang
was a postdoc in the lab was he
um did a screen for mutants that don't
make hyphy
and what he found was uh you could look
for
just at the colony morphology you'd get
these what we call smooth colonies
and so he did uh kyle did a screen of
about half a million colonies and
isolated 65 mutants
uh that were smooth and then of those
mutants he picked
five that did not make hyphy under
any of our tested environmental
conditions
and so obviously one of the things we
want to do is to understand
what mutations cause this so um
oh this is just a little bit more
microscopy looking at the smooth strains
you can see
here's our wild type and you can see the
yeast form
in our um in our smooth mutants
and
one of the things we did was to sequence
the genome of these smooth mutants
and i'm going to kind of sum up a few
years of work in the next few slides
basically uh with these smooth mutants
we found that um it was not
a simple gene hit or mutation
in a single gene that led to the
phenotype what it was
actually was um
uh in a sub-telomeric region we started
to make
in in four out of five of our smooth
mutants we started to make deletions
of repetitive dna and
basically long story short here you can
see that
and this is the easiest one to look at
is this bottom column here
that uh our
the the repeats decrease um
in all of our smooth uh mutants
so the the repetitive region uh the
number of reeds that have that contain
repeats when we do sequencing
decreases in a couple of mutants or
actually all five but in
two in particular our
our presumed amount of rdna in the
genome
also is decreased
and i should note that these smooth
mutants were made in a ku background
so we've gotten rid of non-homologous
end joining dna repair
and there is some kind of evidence out
there that sometimes these mutants can
start to
accumulate uh different kinds of
deletions in
repetitive areas
so we wanted to continue to go after
this and one of the things we did was to
then do a suppressor screen
using one of our smooth mutants to look
for then
suppression of this uh smooth phenotype
so how do we restore hyphal growth
and one of the things we found was that
we started to accumulate
mutations in uh histidine kinase and and
map kinase signaling pathway uh in
particular
nick one and and chk1 these are the two
histine kinases where we saw uh
mutations
and um what that led us to
then was kind of a high-level
view that um
in the ku mutants where we've
accumulated these
deletions in the subtelomeric regions
were
were causing some sort of stress
that is um activating
um these two pathway the hog map kinase
cascade and then some histidine kinases
that essentially then feed into and this
is results i didn't talk about the
transcription factor msn2
that lead to this change in morphology
so again what what we did was
you know looking at these uh mutants
we were able to use high throughput uh
or
you know next-gen it's now current gen i
guess sequencing technologies
to quickly get at the mutations and
start to associate genes with
our morphology phenotype
so we're continuing to do a lot of work
in your this kind of the future
directions of the euroa work
we're doing a lot of uh more synthetic
biology where we do
try to work through our design build
test learn cycle
to develop euroa to make
other kinds of molecules like organic
acids
or terpenoids that may have use in
as biofuels or bioproducts
so i'm gonna i'm gonna the last part i'm
gonna talk about
is about enzyme secretion
and so i always like to tell people
especially if i go into elementary
schools
to talk about fungi and the wonders of
fungal research
that we all live in the fungal digestive
tract so fungi have this great
uh quality of essentially digesting the
environment around them and then
absorbing
those building block nutrients
versus like humans ingesting food and
digesting them
digesting it internally so we all live
in the fun in the digestive tract of
fungi
and that's one of the great qualities
that
led us to use fungi as a protein
production platform so
at the joint bioenergy institute
the goal was to develop some fungi that
could be used to
um produce
thermophilic bacteria enzymes that could
then be used in
biomass deconstruction in the background
of ionic liquids
so ionic liquids are used at jbay to
solubilize biomass
um which is then converted into sugars
and fermented into fuels and chemicals
so we needed a protein production
platform uh
we took a couple of different
thermophilic bacterial
uh beta glucosidases and put them in uh
expressed them in aspergillus niger
and then developed a screen for uh
secretion ahead of this heterologously
expressed
protein so i'm going to zip through this
section um
basically what we found was when we did
the the mutant screen
is that we were able to
even in a background of fungal
biomastigating enzyme activity
um we could increase the percentage of
ionic liquid in our solution and only
the bacterial enzyme really
could survive that kind of uh that kind
of condition
fungal enzymes um were not good and even
as low as five percent ionic liquid
so they they in our assay for bladed
causadases
the fungal enzymes would die so we could
look at
we could do a mutant screen look for use
a plate assay
which i show here to look for increased
secretion of
our heterologously expressed enzyme
in a background of fungal enzymes
because as i mentioned the fungal
enzymes aren't don't survive
ionic liquid
basically we found two types of mutants
and
those mutants were uh either
the um endogenous enzyme
uh increased uh so this is in our
beta glucosidase assay or we saw
an increase in
the heterologously expressed enzyme
so on the the black bar is
uh non-ionic liquid conditions and then
under high ionic liquids so that's
this is higher fungal enzyme this is um
higher heterologously expressed enzyme
and then this is when
both sets of enzymes both the fungal
enzymes and our heterologously expressed
enzyme
are increased in expression and i'm
gonna i'm gonna kind of cut to the chase
here we sequenced a whole bunch of
mutants and we found
um that several strains uh
that were high for only the
heterologously expressed enzyme
had a mutation in a monosaccharide
transporter mstc we grew
we grew these under high maltose um
uh himaltos in the media
and so under this particular condition
um
we we could then look at this
heterologous expression
i mentioned the maltose because this is
a predicted sugar transporter
and um essentially what we found
was that um our heterologous what we
what we ended up screening for you kind
of get what you screened for was that
our construct for heterologous
expression was
uh under the glucoamylase promoter and
so uh
we were essentially screening for not
necessarily an increase in the secretion
pathway
um but um
regulatory mutants in in
for glucoamylase induction
and so that'll figure into i'm going to
skip this and and go to
kind of the last little part of the
message here
uh which is that we not only did our own
screen but then we could
go to strain collections and look at
existing
protein production strain as well as
some neurospheric crassa
classical mutants and resequence all of
them to kind of get a picture of
what genes are involved in enzyme
secretion in filamentous fungi
and so these are just some of the
lineages that we sequenced
so here's trichoderma resii famous for
it's probably the
apparent strain for a number of enzyme
companies and their biomass enzyme
cocktails
the reference is osq m6a and then
there's this
well-known lineage most of which is
deposited in
atcc of of several um
high producing strains these are some
aspergillus nitrous strains that
that produce high levels of glucoamylase
and i'm going to get to the punchline
here and these are some of the genes we
found
there's known regulators of we found a
bunch of basically
known genes cree 1 ace 1 cree a
amylase mer
and the bottom line and then we also
found other sugar transporters that had
been mutated
the bottom line is that
the way to make a hyper secreting fungus
is to one
go after the trans the transporters and
sugar sensing
machinery and then to mutate the
transcriptional regulators
and then there's also some good data
that you can impact the secretion
pathway so what you can do is you can
stack
these kinds of mutations to get what
essentially are
fungi that are secreting industrial
levels of
enzyme so
with that i'm going to end hopefully
i've left enough time for questions
thank you scott my head is spinning
um i was worried i was worried about uh
packing i actually got rid of some
information some slides at the last
minute so
probably a good thing um before i
forget uh everyone
all graduate students and post-docs are
invited
to meet with scott we used to call this
a lunch no longer a lunch but you're
welcome
to eat um starting at
1 45 i believe and
there's a separate link that went out
um let me look at the chat
from claire castille maybe i missed this
do the hyphy mutants have any other
changes in
phenotype mutations in and
signaling seem important
so um
yes uh the the colony obviously the
colony
the colony morphology has changed and
um you think that my my throat would be
used to long zoom meetings i'm a little
bit scratchy now
um there's also these are also pathways
involved in
um so stress response to
osmolarity um so we haven't really
put them through their paces to see all
the i think the phenotypes are
pliotropic
i like i said i can tell you that um
not all of the um
the smooth mutants are um
are super healthy so i'll just leave it
at yes there are pleotropic phenotypes i
didn't talk about them
especially in the osmolarity
signaling and stress response
so i was going to
ask a similar question regarding your
last slide um to make industrial
levels of enzymes but are you alive
no no these are these are pretty unhappy
strains um you know the
the the beauty of trying to figure out
these genes is
so that the trichoderma uh recei
the kind of strain that started it all
is actually uh female sterile
and so the multiple rounds of
mutagenesis just piled up mutations and
so
it's a pretty unhappy strain um
i mean i guess they can always get worse
so that
i think when you start to pile on these
more directed mutations you still make
them
sick but not as sick um
so that's that's kind of the goal is can
we
get rid of the collateral damage and and
try to make them healthier but no
they're they're not happy
second question in the chat um
in the eurovia project histidine kinase
was found
to be related to smooth mutants
what is the biological
function of the histidine kinase
in the organism after phosphorylating
histidine
so i know i know that it's kind of in
that upstream stress
signaling pathway um
some of the more we haven't done a lot
of finer phenotypic mapping
so i i can't really answer that question
because i don't know
um just generally histine kinases are
involved in
in kind of signaling these um
important i think osmo sensing i think
there's
uh some some of histidine kinases are
also involved in
um they get mutated and become resistant
to
fungicides okay i'm trying to remember
the class we've started to
look a little bit at this and some of
our other work
but suffice it to say
these cells are pretty sick i have kind
of an unsubstantiated theory that when
we
made the ku mutants and then screen
these ku mutants for spawn
there was there wasn't really a um
a heavy mutagenesis so the the
i think we picked up mutation or
we picked up strains
where the dna damage
because it was in a ku background was so
great it caused
it it started to look it started to mess
up the regulatory pathways and
in ways that go beyond our genetic
screen
so i i wish i had the funding to follow
up on this that was a long-winded answer
to
i don't know cool stuff
that's okay um another
question um very cool work
thank you for the presentation
thank you general question relating to
the first half
of your presentation
has uh
uh or have you done work with
synthetical
cell imaging or omics
i guess it would technically fall under
single cell omics but they often hold
bacterial cells inside the cytoplasm
so i'm curious if anyone is
trying to tackle this
so trying to make sure i understand the
question basically
are we doing real quick
to unmute marina and
so so synthesial cell imaging
i'm
i'm a little so looking at like for
example bacteria in
as symbionts inside of other cells or
hey thank you yeah um i was mostly
curious
because you mentioned the work on um
multi uh sorry what was the term
your fly fish work oh
yeah and i was just curious if anyone
was looking at sensational cells
where they have like the combined
cytoplasm combined nuclei
and a large cytoplasm so
yes um so
we've been working with um jonathan
schilling
who looks at white rot fungi
degrading wood so yeah i i could go
through different user projects but the
the answer is yes
we're looking at um we are looking at
shared cytoplasm and and
with multiple nuclei we're also
um just to advertise we've been do we've
done some
studies where we've looked at uh
endophytic
uh bacteria in um poplar
so it's there's a lot of uh
answers yes we we we work with users to
customize
um kind of extractions and fixations
and so forth because no one microbe is
the same
or plant okay thank you
yeah follow up with me if you want to
cool
thanks and it's accessible to everybody
so
follow up with me
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu